have one more question while we have you  two here yeah who do you think got it  worst on Impractical Jokers the whole  run punished the worst oh well Sal I  mean he got the most of them out of me  and him no out of all four would you say  me though well you just in quantity I've  been punished the most oh really yeah I  lost the most okay so in quantity am I a  big number or is it like uh I don't  think it's like neck and neck it's  probably a little bit more I don't think  it's like it's double yeah I think it's  you and Murray are like account for like  60 of them there's like someone had a  count on Wikipedia now I don't know what  it is I think it's because they always  make you say the worst thing possible  it's because he's funny to punish man  like he wears it on his face and stuff  okay but as far as like we love doing it  the worst punishments I think probably  Murray has gotten the worst punishments  I'm